Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
I'M A FISHERMAN --
A DARN GOOD ONE.
I'M PAT BOONE.
OH!
HO, HO!
WE CAME HERE
TO MAKE A DEAL.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
WHOA!
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I WANT TO BRING THIS
TO THE AMERICAN MARKET.
WHY DID NOBODY
THINK OF THIS BEFORE?
NOBODY'S AS SMART AS ME.
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
IF SOMEONE HAS A GOOD IDEA AND
COME IN HERE AND SELL US ON IT,
THEY CAN GET
AN INVESTOR.
MARK, WE DON'T HAVE TO
AGREE WITH YOU.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
WHY AREN'T YOU TAKING
THE OFFER?
DO YOU HAVE $200 MILLION
YOU'D LIKE TO PLOP DOWN?
I'M SORRY ABOUT THE TEARS.
YOU'RE TRYING TO BUILD A BAKERY
BEFORE TASTING THE CAKE.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST UP IS
A REVOLUTIONARY NEW WAY
TO POWER TRANSPORTATION.
OH!
HO, HO!
[ CHUCKLES ]
Tucker: HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS
ETHAN TUCKER,
AND I'M FROM THE BEAUTIFUL
GREEN MOUNTAINS
OF BRATTLEBORO, VERMONT.
AND I'M PAT BOONE,
AGING SINGER
AND, LIKE YOU,
A LIFELONG ENTREPRENEUR.
OUR COMPANY
IS ZERO POLLUTION MOTORS,
AND WE ARE SEEKING
$5 MILLION
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 50% OF OUR COMPANY.
OUR GOAL
IS TO GIVE TO AMERICA
THE LEANEST, CLEANEST, GREENEST
FORM OF AUTO TRANSPORTATION
EVER TO HIT
OUR CROWDED, POLLUTED CITIES.
SO, SHARKS,
IT IS MY GREAT PLEASURE
TO INTRODUCE TO YOU...
THE AIR CAR.
[ LAUGHS ]
Herjavec: THE WHAT?
THE CAR THAT RUNS
ON AIR.
WOW.
THAT'S RIGHT, AIR,
BUT HIGHLY COMPRESSED AIR.
[ LAUGHTER ]
THERE IT IS.
AIR, OF COURSE,
IS THE LEAST EXPENSIVE,
MOST READILY AVAILABLE,
AND THE MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY
PERFECT FUEL
THAT WILL EVER BE,
AND THE AirPod
USES COMPRESSED AIR
TO DRIVE THE PISTONS
IN THE ENGINE.
WHAT?
IT IS FAR SUPERIOR
TO THE ELECTRIC CAR
BECAUSE OF ITS PRICE
AND IT ELIMINATES THE NEED
FOR BATTERIES,
WHICH ARE EXPENSIVE
AND INEFFICIENT.
LOOK AT THAT THING GO.
NOW, THIS IS
A PICTURE WE TOOK,
WHICH IS NOT
TOTALLY LIFE-SIZE.
THIS IS JUST
THE FIRST PROTOTYPE.
AND, SO, HOW MANY
WANT TO JOIN US
FOR A DAZZLING RIDE
INTO THE FUTURE?
LOOK, PAT, I KNOW YOU'VE SOLD
OVER 40 MILLION RECORDS.
THEY SAY.
I DIDN'T GET PAID THAT MANY,
BUT YES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHAT WAS YOUR BIGGEST HIT?
I'M JUST CURIOUS.
"LOVE LETTERS
IN THE SAND."
YOU KNOW, I LOVE CARS.
I DO.
I RACE CARS.
WHAT MADE YOU THINK
I WOULDN'T WANT TO GET IN IT
AND TRY IT?
[ LAUGHS ]
WELL --
WHY ISN'T IT HERE?
I KNOW, WE WOULD LIKE YOU
TO BE IN IT,
AND THERE'S
SEVERAL REASONS.
ONE IS THAT THE CAR, TO COME
INTO THE UNITED STATES,
HAS TO MEET
SAFETY STANDARDS.
IT HAS IN EUROPE
ALREADY.
OH, SO THIS IS ALREADY
A PRODUCTION CAR.
IT IS MOVING
INTO PRODUCTION.
AND YOU'VE BOUGHT
THE LICENSE TO IT,
OR YOU WANT TO BUY
THE LICENSING?
WE HAVE THE RIGHT
TO BUILD THE FIRST PLANT
IN THE UNITED STATES.
SO, ETHAN, WHERE --
Greiner:
IN THE UNITED STATES?
YOU SHOULD EXPLAIN
HOW IT'S POWERED.
IS THIS COMPRESSED AIR?
IT IS COMPRESSED AIR.
IT IS NOT
A COMBUSTION PRINCIPLE.
IT IS
A PROPULSION PRINCIPLE.
NOW, A CRUDE WAY TO ILLUSTRATE
WOULD BE BLOW UP A BALLOON.
[ EXHALES SHARPLY ]
PBBBBTH.
IT TAKES OFF.
PAT, HOW FAST DOES
THE LUNCHBOX ON WHEELS GO?
[ LAUGHTER ]
IT WOULD GO ABOUT
50 MILES AN HOUR, TOPS.
Herjavec:
IT IS SELF-PERPETUATING?
IN OTHER WORDS, IS THERE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF COMPRESSED AIR
WITHIN THE VEHICLE TO LAST
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME?
YOU PLUG IN THE AirPod
TO ANY OUTLET...
OKAY.
...AND IT TAKES
FOUR HOURS TO CHARGE.
THE MOTOR CHARGES ITSELF.
IT COMPRESSES THE AIR.
HOW LONG DOES IT LAST?
YOU HAVE
100 MILES RANGE.
I'M A CONSUMER.
I'M COMING TO A STORE TO BUY
AN AIR CAR OR A BATTERY CAR.
OKAY.
YEAH.
TELL ME WHY
I'M GONNA BUY THE AIR CAR.
THERE'S ONE
BIG DIFFERENCE.
TELL ME.
OTHER THAN THE PRICE --
TELL ME!
I'LL TELL YOU!
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
THE DIFFERENCE IS, IF THERE'S
A COMPRESSOR AT A GAS STATION,
JUST LIKE YOU FILL UP
YOUR TIRES,
YOU CAN FILL UP YOUR CAR
IN FOUR MINUTES.
WHAT'S THE COST?
$10,000.
$10,000 FOR
THE AIR CAR?
THE CAR COSTS $10,000?
THAT'S IT?
YEAH.
THAT'S IT!
SOMETHING'S WRONG HERE.
NO, BECAUSE
IT'S VERY SIMPLY MADE.
THE INVENTOR -- YOU MAY KNOW
THE NAME -- GUY NEGRE.
YEAH, DOESN'T -- ISN'T HE
THE GUY WHO DEVELOPED THE...
TITANIUM PISTON.
TITANIUM
FOR A LIGHTER MOTOR.
HE'S GOT 150 PATENTS.
HE KNOWS DEVELOPMENT.
SO HE'S A REAL CAR GUY.
HE LOVES CARS.
RIGHT.
WHAT WOULD IT COST FOR YOU
TO BRING YOUR CAR HERE?
WELL, YOU'RE GONNA
MANUFACTURE IT HERE, I THOUGHT.
WE'RE GONNA MANUFACTURE
IN HAWAII.
YEAH,
WE'RE GONNA MANUFACTURE --
WE'RE BRINGING IT
TO THE UNITED STATES.
HAWAII?
THE $5 MILLION IS FOR
A PLANT TO BUI--
REGIONAL PLANT
TO BUILD THE CARS.
WHY HAWAII?
HAWAII IS A SORT OF
ENCLOSED COMMUNITY
WHERE THEY HAVE
POLLUTION PROBLEMS,
THEY HAVE
HIGH COST OF GAS,
AND IT'S MORE OF
A CONTROLLED PLACE.
PART OF THE CONCEPT
OF THE COMPANY
IS NOT A BIG
DETROIT-TYPE PLANT.
IT IS REGIONAL PLANTS,
SMALL PLANTS,
BUILDING CARS
FOR THAT AREA.
PAT, CAN YOU SHARE
WHAT IT'S MADE OUT OF?
FIBERGLASS, POLYURETHANE,
AND RESIN.
YOU CAN JUMP ON A DOOR,
AND IT WON'T BEND
LIKE A REGULAR CAR.
BUT WHAT ABOUT
IN A CRASH TEST?
SO, WE CAN'T PASS A CRASH TEST
UNTIL WE'VE CRASHED A CAR,
AND WE DON'T WANT TO CRASH
A PROTOTYPE.
WE ONLY HAVE
THREE PROTOTYPES,
SO WE WOULD BE CRASHING --
TESTING A CAR
THAT WAS BUILT FROM SCRATCH.
$5 MILLION TO BUILD YOUR FACTORY
IN HAWAII.
THEN YOU HAVE TO MARKET IT,
RIGHT?
YEAH, YEAH.
AND NOT ONLY DO YOU HAVE TO
LET PEOPLE KNOW IT EXISTS,
YOU HAVE TO CONVINCE THEM
THAT THEY CAN TRUST IT.
YEAH, YEAH.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY
WE'RE IN HAWAII --
BECAUSE WE WANT TO DO IT
SLOWLY.
OKAY, SO YOUR LICENSE IS NOT FOR
ALL OF THE UNITED STATES
ON AN EXCLUSIVE BASIS.
NO, IT'S FOR
THIS ONE PLANT.
THE COMPANY'S CALLED MDI,
AND THEY'VE JUST MADE A DEAL
WITH TATA MOTORS FOR INDIA,
A $30 MILLION DEAL,
SO THEY WRAPPED UP INDIA.
AND THE MDI COMPANY
HAS ALL OF FRANCE.
SO, THEY'RE ONLY ISSUING
A COUPLE PLANTS PER TERRITORY?
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
Boone:
AREAS, REGIONS, YEAH.
JUST SO WE CAN BE CRYSTAL-CLEAR
ON THE OPPORTUNITY.
YEAH.
I'M ASSUMING THAT I BECOME A 50%
PARTNER IN A PLANT IN HAWAII
AND THAT I OWN
THAT ENTIRE TERRITORY.
EVERY CAR SOLD
ON EVERY ISLAND IN HAWAII
IS COMING FROM THAT PLANT.
IS THAT TRUE?
YES.
BUT IF SOMEBODY BUILDS A PLANT
IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND SHIPS A CAR
INTO MY TERRITORY --
NOT ALLOWED.
CANNOT HAPPEN.
GUYS, GUYS, I'M GONNA
SIMPLIFY THINGS HERE, RIGHT?
THE SMART THING, AS AN INVESTOR,
IS TO JUST WATCH WHAT HAPPENS
WITH TATA MOTORS IN INDIA,
SEE HOW IT SELLS,
LOOK AT THEIR EXPERIENCE,
AND THEN, IF IT GOES GOOD, WATCH
SOMEBODY ELSE OPEN UP A PLANT --
YOU'RE TOO LATE. THIS IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
THIS WAVE IS CRESTING.
IF IT WAS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW,
YOU WOULDN'T BE HERE.
YOU'D ALREADY HAVE THE MONEY
AND HAVE THE PLANT OPEN.
NO, IT'S --
GUYS, I'M OUT.
THE STRATEGY
OF TRYING TO BUY A LICENSE
FOR A SINGLE PLANT
IS ALMOST LUDICROUS.
IF YOU CAN'T TIE UP
AN ENTIRE REGION,
YOU'RE BUYING THE RIGHT
TO BECOME A DEALER IN HAWAII.
YOU'VE GOT TO LOCK UP
ALL OF UNITED STATES.
DO YOU HAVE $200 MILLION YOU'D
LIKE TO PLOP DOWN FOR THAT?
YOU BECOME THE PIONEERS.
YOU ESTABLISH A REGION
FOR $5 MILLION,
PROVE THE MODEL,
AND SOMEBODY ELSE SCOOPS
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME
AS AN INVESTOR.
WE WILL BE THE FIRST.
I GET IT --
BUT NOT THE LAST.
AND WE HAVE
THE INSIDE CONNECTION TO MDI.
I CAN GO TO MDI
AND SIMPLY DO A DEAL RIGHT NOW,
WITHOUT YOU,
FOR NEW YORK.
WELL, HERE'S MY ANSWER
TO THAT.
TRY, BECAUSE OUR --
WHY, 'CAUSE THEY DON'T WANT
MY CAR IN NEW YORK OR MY MONEY?
NO, THEY DON'T WANT TO BE
DOUBLE-CROSSED.
THERE'S A TRUST FACTOR.
OUR COMPANY --
YOU COULD NOT GO DIRECTLY
TO GUY AND SAY,
"I'M GONNA PLOP DOWN
$5 MILLION,"
AND COMPLETELY
DOUBLE-CROSS US.
Herjavec:
YEAH, YOU KNOW WHAT?
PUSH COMES TO SHOVE,
THEIR COMPANY GETS IN TROUBLE
AND KEVIN COMES ALONG WITH A
$5 MILLION OFFER FOR THE RIGHTS.
$5 MILLION, TO GUY,
IS SMALL POTATOES.
THE WAY TO MAKE THIS WORK
IS TO SIT DOWN
AND COME UP WITH
A NATIONAL STRATEGY
FOR THE ENTIRE U.S. MARKET
AND THEN PACKAGE THAT UP
AND BRING IT TO INVESTORS.
YOU'RE TRYING TO BUILD A BAKERY
BEFORE TASTING THE CAKE.
THAT'S RIGHT, BUT WE'RE
GONNA ALLOW OTHERS
TO TASTE THE CAKE.
THAT'S WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN WAITING FOR.
I KNOW THE CHALLENGES
OF ALL THE LEGAL ISSUES,
BRINGING A PRODUCT TO MARKET
LIKE THIS.
IT COULD TAKE FOREVER,
AND IT'S TOO EARLY FOR ME,
WITHOUT YOUR ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY GET CLEARANCE
TO HAVE THIS OPERATE IN AMERICA,
SO BECAUSE OF THAT, I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW,
I LIKE GREEN PRODUCTS.
I THINK THAT THIS COMPRESSED-AIR
CONCEPT COULD BE A HERO.
BUT FOR ME, YOU WOULD
HAVE TO HAVE HAD THE RIGHTS
TO ALL OF THE U.S.A.
FOR ME TO REALLY BE INTERESTED.
I'M OUT.
YOUR DEAL DOESN'T MAKE A LOT
OF SENSE FOR A SHARK AT ALL,
BECAUSE THE RETURN EXPECTATIONS
ON THIS ARE FAR IN THE FUTURE.
IT'S A MONUMENTAL TASK.
NOBODY WANTS TO LAUNCH THIS
IN HAWAII.
I'M CERTAINLY NOT GONNA DO IT.
I THINK I'VE ARTICULATED WHY.
YEAH.
YOU MAY HAVE A SHARK
WHO'S SO INGRAINED
IN THE AUTOMOTIVE INDUSTRY.
HE MAY BE CRAZY ENOUGH TO DO IT.
WE'RE GONNA FIND OUT RIGHT NOW.
BUT I'M OUT.
Narrator:
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
ROBERT IS PAT AND ETHAN'S
LAST CHANCE FOR A DEAL
FOR THEIR AIR-PROPELLED VEHICLE,
AIR CAR.
I'VE INVESTED IN
A LOT OF THINGS,
AND I'M WILLING TO INVEST
IN THIS, TOO.
LOOK, I'M INTERESTED.
I'M -- I'M REALLY INTERESTED.
AND HE'S FULL OF HOT AIR.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YEAH!
IT'S A LOW-COST COMMUTER CAR
FOR $10,000 --
BIG MARKET FOR THAT.
MM-HMM.
THE $5 MILLION
ISN'T THAT MUCH,
CONSIDERING
THE SIZE OF THIS MARKET.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
YOU'RE GONNA SELL
ONE STATE AT A TIME,
MY FRIENDS.
THE MINUTE YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL
IN HAWAII,
SOMEBODY IS GONNA LOCK UP
THE OTHER STUFF.
I DON'T WANT TO MAKE AIR CARS
IN HAWAII.
I WANT TO BRING THIS
TO THE AMERICAN MARKET.
I'M HAPPY TO GIVE YOU $5 MILLION
FOR THE RIGHT
TO GO AND SIT AT
THAT TABLE AND NEGOTIATE
A DISTRIBUTION DEAL
WITH THE PEOPLE WHO OWN IT.
SO I'M GIVING YOU
$5 MILLION FOR 50%,
CONTINGENT ON BEING ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE AN AMERICAN-WIDE DEAL.
AND IF YOU DON'T GET
THAT DEAL...
WELL, IT'S CONTINGENT ON THAT,
'CAUSE I DON'T BUY --
THEN IT'S --
THE $5 MILLION GOES AWAY.
GUY NEGRE
WOULD BE THRILLED
TO HAVE YOU MAKE A DEAL
WITH HIM,
AND I FEEL VERY CERTAIN THAT
THAT NUMBER COULD COME DOWN,
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY,
HAVING THE U.S. RIGHTS
IS THE GOLDEN GOOSE.
RIGHT.
WHY ARE YOU EVEN
HESITATING?
WELL, I --
WE'RE NOT.
I WANT TO ADD ONE OTHER FILL-UP
THAT YOU WOULD BE PURCHASING,
AND THAT IS
THE GOLF CART.
PAT,
YOU GOT TO STOP SELLING
Cuban: PAT, DON'T TALK YOURSELF
OUT OF A DEAL.
YOU'VE GOT TO MAKE
A DECISION.
Greiner:
DOES THAT MEAN YES?
WE HAVE A DEAL!
OH, MY GOSH! YEAH!
[ LAUGHS ]
WHAT AN HONOR
TO MEET YOU, PAT.
THANK YOU.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
YOU ARE THE PERFECT,
PERFECT PERSON.
I AM THE PERFECT PERSON
FOR THIS. I LOVE CARS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. GOOD LUCK.
Cuban: CONGRATS.
Greiner: THANK YOU GUYS.
Herjavec: THANK YOU.
Tucker: WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH
THE REINVENTION OF THE MOTOR,
THAT LEAP OF FAITH
IS THE LEAP
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE ON
THE GROUND FLOOR HAVE TO TAKE.
MM-HMM.
AND WE'VE BEEN PROVEN RIGHT
FOR OUR -- FOR TAKING THE JUMP.
HIGH FIVE, ROBERT.
I LIKE THAT.
AWESOME.
THERE MIGHT BE SOMETHING THERE.
I HOPE THERE IS.
Narrator: EARLIER THIS SEASON,
WE SAW CHEF HEIDI LOVIG
MAKE A DEAL WITH LORI GREINER
FOR HER VEGAN-CHEESE COMPANY,
HEIDI HO.
Lovig:
WE'RE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
IN FOUR REGIONS
OF WHOLE FOODS MARKET.
I HAVE ALREADY SECURED GROWTH
INTO FIVE MORE REGIONS
WITH THEM,
AND I NEED WORKING CAPITAL
TO EXECUTE AGAINST THAT GROWTH.
Narrator:
LET'S SEE WHAT SHE'S UP TO NOW.
OH, MY GOSH,
BUSINESS HAS EXPLODED
SINCE BEING ON "SHARK TANK."
IN THE 12 MONTHS
LEADING UP TO "SHARK TANK,"
OUR SALES WERE $140,000.
IT'S ONLY BEEN FOUR MONTHS
SINCE BEING ON "SHARK TANK,"
AND OUR SALES ARE $750,000.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TRY
SOME CHEESE?
TODAY, I AM IN CHICAGO
DOING AN IN-STORE DEMO,
BECAUSE THEY REALLY ALLOW ME
TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC
ABOUT OUR DELICIOUS
PLANT-BASED CHEESES.
I'D LIKE TO TRY
SOME CHEESE.
LORI!
[ LAUGHS ]
COME HERE!
HI!
Greiner: YOU KNOW WHAT'S GREAT
ABOUT HEIDI?
SHE'S SOCIALLY CONSCIOUS,
SHE'S HARDWORKING,
SHE'S SO TENACIOUS,
AND THE PRODUCT IS AMAZING.
SHE MAKES IT WITH LOVE.
I'M SO GLAD
THAT WE GOT INTO
OVER 300 WHOLE FOODS STORES
LIKE THAT.
IT'S REALLY NOT EASY TO BUILD
A BRAND AND A NAME FOR YOURSELF
IN THE NATURAL-FOOD INDUSTRY
WITH A PRODUCT
THAT'S SO UNIQUE
AND SO NEW TO SO MANY PEOPLE.
IT'S REALLY GOOD.
REALLY GOOD, RIGHT?
LORI WAS THE SHARK THAT CAME IN
WHEN WE WERE SUPER VULNERABLE
AND TOOK A RISK ON US.
I LOVE HEIDI HO,
AND YOU'RE DOING AMAZING.
TOGETHER,
I KNOW WE WILL BECOME
THE NEXT BIG NAME
IN NATURAL FOOD.
HI. I'M SHAUNA SLEDGE
FROM FORT COLLINS, COLORADO.
I LIVE WITH MY HUSBAND, TODD,
OUR TWO GIRLS,
STEPHANIE AND MEGHAN,
AND OUR LITTLE BOY, SKYLAR.
SO, I'M A WORKING MOM.
YOUR GUMS FEEL OKAY?
I'M A PART-TIME
DENTAL HYGIENIST.
COME ON!
I'M A GROUP-FITNESS
INSTRUCTOR.
GOOD JOB!
AND I HAVE MY OWN BUSINESS
THAT I RUN.
LIVING A HEALTHY
AND ACTIVE LIFESTYLE
HAS ALWAYS BEEN
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME.
A BIG PART OF BEING HEALTHY
IS WHAT YOU EAT,
AND I'M A TRUE BELIEVER
IN THE PALEO DIET.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS,
LET'S DIG IN.
THE PALEO DIET MIMICS THE DIET
OF OUR ANCIENT ANCESTORS.
IT CONSISTS OF EATING
LEAN PROTEIN,
AVOIDING DAIRY, POTATOES,
LEGUMES, AND PROCESSED FOODS.
BASICALLY, IF THE CAVEMAN
DIDN'T HAVE IT, DON'T EAT IT.
WE WILL BE SHIPPING IT OUT
IN TWO DAYS.
WE'RE IN AN EXTREMELY
COMPETITIVE MARKET.
I REALLY FEEL LIKE I NEED
THE SHARKS AND THEIR INFLUENCE
AND THEIR CONNECTIONS
FOR US TO SURVIVE.
I'M A VERY COMPETITIVE PERSON,
AND I WON'T LET
THIS BUSINESS FAIL,
BECAUSE I HAVE
SO MANY PEOPLE COUNTING ON ME,
AND I WON'T LET THEM DOWN.
[ GASPS ]
[ Chuckling ] OH.
OH, LORD.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS SHAUNA SLEDGE.
I'M FROM FORT COLLINS, COLORADO,
AND OUR COMPANY
IS THE PALEO DIET FOODS.
WE ARE SEEKING JUST $150,000
FOR 20% EQUITY IN OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, WE NEED
A CHANGE IN LIFESTYLE.
WE NEED TO GO BACK
TO OUR ROOTS -- WAY BACK.
BACK THEN, IT WAS FORAGING
FOR BERRIES AND NUTS.
WELL, NOWADAYS,
IT'S FORAGING FOR ANYTHING
THAT DOESN'T CONTAIN
POTASSIUM BENZOATE
OR OTHER STUFF
THAT'S HARD TO PRONOUNCE.
WELL, FORAGE NO MORE,
BECAUSE EVERYTHING YOU'VE BEEN
SEEKING IS IN ONE BAR --
THE PALEO DIET BAR...
...POWERED BY
17 GRAMS OF PROTEIN,
CONTAINING ALL NINE
ESSENTIAL AMINO ACIDS.
IT'S FREE OF GLUTEN.
IT'S FREE OF SOY, DAIRY.
SO, TO BE A PART
OF THE PALEOLITHIC MOVEMENT
DOESN'T MEAN YOU HAVE TO LIVE
LIKE YOU'RE IN
THE PALEOLITHIC ERA.
JUST REACH FOR
THE PALEO DIET BAR.
IT'S PACKED WITH RAW,
ALL-NATURAL INGREDIENTS...
[ LAUGHTER ]
...THAT, WELL, OBVIOUSLY,
THIS GUY EVEN RECOGNIZES.
OUR PRODUCT IS
THE ONLY EVER ENDORSED PRODUCT
BY DR. LOREN CORDAIN,
THE FOUNDER OF
THE PALEOLITHIC MOVEMENT.
SO COME ON, SHARKS,
LET'S DO THIS!
ARE YOU GUYS READY
TO EAT NATURALLY?
YEAH.
LET'S TRY IT.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, WHAT I'M THRILLED
TO FIND OUT
IS THAT CAVEMEN HAD TO
WEAR WEDDING RINGS, TOO.
[ LAUGHS ]
I KIND OF KNOW THAT GUY.
YOU DO?
IS THAT YOUR HUSBAND?
Sledge:MM, IT IS.
[ GREINER CHUCKLES ]
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec: THANK YOU.
YOU ARE A GENTLEMAN.
IS THERE NUTS?
YES, THERE ARE.
THEY'RE ONLY TREE NUTS.
THERE'S NO PEANUTS,
BECAUSE IT'S PALEO DIET.
SHAUNA,
IT TASTES GREAT.
THANK YOU.
MOST OF THE PROTEIN STUFF I EAT
TASTES PRETTY CRAPPY.
IT'S 17 GRAMS
OF EGG-WHITE PROTEIN.
WHY SO MUCH SUGAR?
WELL, IT'S THE FRUIT.
IT HAS PRETTY EQUAL ENERGIES
OF CARBS, PROTEIN, AND FAT,
SO IT KIND OF OFFSETS
ONE ANOTHER.
SHAUNA, WHAT'S IN THIS ONE,
THE ONE YOU CUT UP?
THERE'S CRANBERRIES, RAISINS,
ALMONDS, SUNFLOWERS,
EGG-WHITE PROTEIN.
IT'S GOOD, THOUGH.
SO, HAVE YOU HEARD
OF THE PALEO DIET?
TELL ME ABOUT
THE PALEO DIET.
I HAVE.
O'Leary:
SHAUNA, YOU LOOK PRETTY BUFF.
ARE YOU ON THE PALEO DIET?
I AM.
I AM ALSO A FITNESS INSTRUCTOR,
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT KIND OF GOT US
IN THE INDUSTRY.
SO, PALEO'S
BASICALLY A LIFESTYLE.
YOU'RE GETTING RID
OF REFINED SUGARS.
YOU GET RID OF
LEGUMES AND POTATOES,
DAIRY, AND THEN GRAINS.
SO, BASICALLY,
YOU EAT LIKE A CAVEMAN.
CAVEWOMAN. [ GRUNTS ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU'RE BUFF.
YEAH.
WELL, AND, SO,
I AM A GROUP-FITNESS INSTRUCTOR.
HOW MANY HOURS A DAY
ARE YOU TEACHING CLASSES?
JUST ONE NOW.
I USED TO TEACH A LOT MORE,
BUT I HAVE THREE KIDS,
AND THEN WE HAVE THIS COMPANY.
[ Laughing ] THREE KIDS.
SO, SHAUNA, HOW DID YOU GO FROM
A FITNESS INSTRUCTOR,
THREE KIDS, TO THIS BAR?
WELL, IN FORT COLLINS,
THE DOCTOR, DR. CORDAIN,
WHO INVENTED THE PALEO DIET,
LIVES THERE.
AND MY PROFESSIONAL TRAINING
IS A DENTAL HYGIENIST,
SO HE HAPPENED TO BE
ONE OF MY PATIENTS.
AND I CALLED HIM AND SAID,
YOU KNOW,
"WE'RE GONNA MAKE THIS BAR.
WE'RE GONNA CALL IT 'PALEO.'
WHAT DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
US USING THAT?"
DID YOU LICENSE IT
FROM HIM?
YEAH, HE HAS 5% OF THE COMPANY,
10% ROYALTIES.
HIS NAME IS KEVIN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
O'Leary: I LIKE IT.
WOW.
I WANT TO BE THE DOCTOR.
SO, WE STARTED THIS PROCESS,
MADE THESE BARS,
GOT THEM INTO THE MARKETPLACE --
MOSTLY IN COLORADO,
IN WHOLE FOODS.
SHAUNA,
DO YOU HAVE SALES?
THE TOTAL SALES
ARE $135,000.
THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
Greiner: JUST IN WHOLE FOODS,
OR ARE YOU OTHER PLACES?
WE ARE IN OVER 350
BRICK-AND-MORTAR LOCATIONS.
WHY AREN'T YOU IN
MORE WHOLE FOODS?
OH, SO, WE ARE.
SO, THAT'S PART OF
WHY I NEED YOU GUYS,
BECAUSE I WANT TO BRING ON
A BROKER.
AND, SO, WE HAVE THEM
ON THE DISTRIBUTION SIDE
FOR A VERY
SHOESTRING BUDGET.
WHAT DOES IT COST
TO MAKE A BAR,
AND WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
YEAH, WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
THE HARD COST --
THAT'S, LIKE, SHIPPING, PALLET,
GET IT TO MY WAREHOUSE --
WAS $1.09 PER BAR.
SO IT'S $1.09 PER BAR.
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
AND, SO, RETAIL IS $2.99.
SEEMS LOW.
WE'RE WORKING ON OUR MARGINS.
WE'RE AT 25%.
AND ANOTHER REASON
I NEED YOU GUYS --
'CAUSE I WOULD LIKE YOU TO HELP
ME NEGOTIATE OUR BUYING POWER.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES ONLINE,
SHAUNA?
OUR ONLINE SALES
ARE ABOUT $45,000.
YOU HAVE GREAT ENERGY,
BUT I HAVE TO BE HONEST.
OKAY.
I DON'T LIKE
THE TASTE OF THE BAR.
I JUST REALLY DON'T LIKE
THE TASTE OF THE BAR...
AND SOME PEOPLE DON'T.
...AND, SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I MUST GO OUT.
OKAY.
AND, YOU KNOW,
I THINK, AS WE GROW,
WE CAN MAYBE TWEAK THE TASTE,
YOU KNOW --
SHAUNA,
I LIKE THE TASTE.
IT TASTES BETTER THAN
SOME OF THE OTHER STUFF.
BUT LET'S
GO BACK TO THIS.
IS THIS
YOUR FULL-TIME JOB?
IT IS.
THE ONLY THING I DO
ON THURSDAY AFTERNOONS
IS SEE MY DENTAL PATIENTS.
YOU'RE A DENTAL HYGIENIST.
WELL, WHAT ABOUT
TEACHING CLASSES?
OH, JUST IN THE MORNING,
EARLY.
'CAUSE I HAVE TO START AROUND
4:00 IN THE MORNING.
YOU KNOW, I NEED HELP...
YOU THINK?
...BECAUSE WE'VE CREATED
A NICE FOUNDATION, MORE BARS,
AND SO I CAN'T BACKTRACK.
SHAUNA --
I THINK -- I THINK YOU'RE
SPREADING YOURSELF TOO THIN,
BUT YOU'RE ALSO
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT.
I HONESTLY AM.
AND I'M LIKE,
DON'T GIVE UP ON ME,
BECAUSE YOU GUYS
HAVE ALL BEEN THERE.
YOU KNOW -- YOU KNOW THE
DETERMINATION AND WHAT IT TAKES.
[ Voice breaking ]
AND I KNOW I AM BUSY.
I AM.
BUT I WON'T LET IT DIE,
BECAUSE DR. CORDAIN WAS BEING
COURTED BY TWO MAJOR COMPANIES,
ONE IN CHICAGO --
I'M SORRY ABOUT THE TEARS.
[ INHALES SHARPLY ]
ONE IN CHICAGO
AND ONE IN BOSTON.
AND HE TRUSTS US, BECAUSE
WE WILL DO RIGHT BY HIM.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT MIGHT TAKE
A LITTLE BIT LONGER
WITHOUT YOU GUYS,
BUT I'M NOT GONNA STOP.
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE YOU
BY MY SIDE --
YOU KNOW, WHOEVER BELIEVES IN
THE PALEO DIET.
SHAUNA, I'VE BEEN
QUIETLY LISTENING TO YOU.
I KNOW.
I'M SCARED OF THAT.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF ENERGY,
AND IT SPRAYS OUT OF YOU
LIKE THE SUN IN 360 DIRECTIONS,
RIGHT?
YOU'RE LIKE A SUPERNOVA JUST
BLOWING UP IN EVERY DIRECTION.
AND THAT'S NOT GOOD IN BUSINESS.
YOU GOT TO HAVE A FOCUS.
I THINK, PERSONALLY, THE ONLINE
STRATEGY WOULD BE BETTER.
IT'S FULL MARGIN.
YOU HAVE A BRAND
ON A SEARCH BASIS.
YOU KNOW, NUT BARS LIKE CUBAN
WHO WANT TO EAT ROCKS --
THIS IS WHAT HE GOES FOR.
THIS IS THE STUFF.
THOSE HARD-CORE PEOPLE
ARE SEARCHING YOU OUT
'CAUSE YOU OWN THE BRAND,
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M HEARING.
I'M HEARING A LOT OF,
YOU KNOW --
A LOT OF DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS.
YOU'RE SCATTERED.
YOU ARE.
AND THAT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU CAN'T FIX YOURSELF,
OR MAYBE FIND A SHARK
THAT'S GONNA SIT DOWN
AND HARNESS YOUR ENERGY.
IT'S NOT GONNA BE ME.
I'M OUT.
HERE'S MY ISSUE.
I DON'T THINK YOU DO ENOUGH.
I THINK DENTAL HYGIENIST,
FITNESS INSTRUCTOR,
MOM OF THREE, WIFE,
AND YOU HAVE PALEO.
YOU COULD DO MORE
WITH YOUR DAY.
I WORK AT 4:00 IN THE MORNING
TILL WHATEVER AT NIGHT.
NO, I GOT IT. I --
I MANAGE IT.
I HAVE THE DAY.
EVERY MINUTE YOU SPEND
DOING ONE THING,
YOU'RE MAKING A CONSCIOUS CHOICE
NOT TO DO ANOTHER THING.
AND SO --
AND I'M NOT SAYING
THAT'S RIGHT OR WRONG,
BUT BE GREAT AT
ONE THING.
DON'T TRY TO BE GREAT
AT MULTIPLE THINGS.
I'M NOT SEEING THAT
IN YOUR PITCH TODAY.
I'M SORRY. I'M OUT.
I HAVE NO DOUBT YOU'RE GONNA
MAKE THIS THING WORK,
BUT YOU ARE A LITTLE BIT
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
YOU SHOULD HAVE CAME INTO
THIS ROOM LASER-FOCUSED,
AND I CAN'T TAKE THIS RIDE
WITH YOU AT THE MOMENT.
I'M OUT.
MARK.
I CAN DO THIS.
I CAN BE LASER-FOCUSED,
AND IF IT REQUIRES ME GIVING UP
TEACHING AND HYGIENE,
THEY ALL UNDERSTAND.
I'M JUST A VERY LOYAL PERSON.
IT HAS TO DO WITH LOYALTY.
Cuban: I KNOW YOU ARE.
WE CAN TELL.
LOOK, I'M A BIG BELIEVER
IN PALEO, RIGHT?
MM-HMM.
I MEAN, I INVESTED IN
A COMPANY CALLED CHAPUL...
OH, YES.
...WHICH IS CRICKETS --
CRICKET-BASED PROTEIN.
IT'S ABOUT AS PALEO
AS YOU CAN GET, RIGHT?
OH, YEAH.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
DR. CORDAIN'S ENDORSEMENT.
NO, THEY DON'T.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S KIND OF
MY DISAPPOINTMENT,
BECAUSE HAVING THAT AND
HAVING THE NAME IS PHENOMENAL
AS AN OPPORTUNITY.
AND WE WANT
TO GROW THE BRAND.
BUT YOU DON'T KNOW
HOW TO GET THERE,
AND THAT'S PART
OF THE PROBLEM,
AND THAT'S WHY YOU'VE HEDGED
YOUR BET SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
YOU KNOW, HONESTLY,
I DIDN'T LIKE THE BARS.
AND I THINK THEY HAVE
TOO MUCH SUGAR IN THEM.
AND WE CAN TWEAK THAT.
YOU KNOW,
I'VE ALREADY TALKED TO THE --
I CAN'T COME IN
AND REDESIGN YOUR PRODUCT.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
Greiner:
EVERYBODY'S OUT, UNFORTUNATELY.
WELL, THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
I WISH YOU THE BEST.
I WISH YOU
ALL THE BEST.
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD LUCK, CAVEMAN.
YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
DANG IT.
Sledge: [ Crying ]
I JUST -- I FELT DISAPPOINTED.
TOO MANY PEOPLE ARE COUNTING ON
THE SUCCESS OF THE PALEO DIET,
AND I WILL NEVER GIVE UP,
BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, IF IT WEREN'T FOR
MY COMMUNITY AND MY FAMILY
AND DR. CORDAIN,
WE WOULDN'T BE WHERE WE ARE NOW,
AND I CAN'T GIVE UP ON THEM.
I DON'T WANT TO GIVE UP ON THEM.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS AN ENTREPRENEUR
WHO HOPES TO LURE THE SHARKS
WITH A BIG FISH.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS GREG MYERSON.
AND I'M FROM
WALLINGFORD, CONNECTICUT.
MY COMPANY IS THE WORLD RECORD
STRIPER COMPANY,
AND I'M SEEKING $75,000 IN
EXCHANGE FOR 20% OF MY COMPANY.
SHARKS, I'M A FISHERMAN --
A DARN GOOD ONE.
THAT'S BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT TO CATCH BIG FISH,
YOU HAVE TO USE THE RIGHT BAIT.
SO IF I'M FISHING FOR A SHARK,
I'M PROBABLY GONNA USE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
[ CUBAN LAUGHS ]
THERE YOU GO.
WHOA!
YEAH, I FIGURED
YOU COULD USE SOME CASH.
COME ON!
Cuban:
THAT'S REAL MONEY.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I'M THROWING THAT ONE BACK.
IT'S ONES.
BUT WHEN I'M FISHING FOR FISH,
I USE MY VERY OWN PRODUCT --
THE GREG MYERSON RattleSinker.
THE RattleSinker ATTRACTS
BIG FISH TO YOUR HOOK
BY MIMICKING THE SOUNDS
OF FISH'S FAVORITE FOODS.
[ SINKER RATTLING ]
YOU HEAR THAT?
TO A FISH, THAT'S THE SOUND
OF A DINNER BELL RINGING.
MY PRODUCT HAS MADE ME
ONE OF THE MOST FAMOUS FISHERMEN
IN THE WORLD, AND HERE'S WHY.
SHARKS, THAT'S THE 82-POUND
WORLD-RECORD STRIPED BASS.
YOU CAUGHT THAT?
YES, I DID --
THE MOST SOUGHT-AFTER
WORLD RECORD
IN ALL THE FISHING WORLD.
Together: WOW.
WOW, THAT COULD HAVE
KNOCKED OVER YOUR BOAT.
SO, SHARKS, IT TOOK 29 YEARS
FOR THAT RECORD TO FALL
AND ABOUT AN HOUR
FOR ME TO REEL IT IN.
I HOPE IT DOESN'T TAKE ME
THAT LONG
TO NET A DEAL
WITH ONE OF YOU.
I GOT SOME PRODUCT
TO SHOW YOU.
THANK YOU, GREG.
YES, SIR.
OKAY.
[ SINKERS RATTLING ]
IT'S KIND OF LIKE A RATTLE.
YES, IT IS A RATTLE.
DID YOU CATCH THAT FISH
USING THIS PRODUCT?
YES, I DID.
AND I HAVE THREE OTHER
WORLD RECORDS WITH THAT PRODUCT.
STRIPED BASS IS
AMERICA'S FISH.
IT'S THE MOST SOUGHT-AFTER
WORLD RECORD.
WHY?
'CAUSE IT'S
THE EVERYMAN QUALITY.
EVERYBODY CAN FISH FOR THIS.
YOU DON'T NEED A YACHT.
YOU CAN FISH FROM SHORE.
I GO TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD
EVERY SUMMER...
YEAH?
...AND THAT IS
THE FISHERMAN'S DREAM THERE,
IS THE STRIPED BASS.
ABSOLUTELY.
WELL, THIS PRODUCT CATCHES
MORE THAN STRIPED BASS.
IT CATCHES ALL FISH.
SO, WHY IS THIS THE BEST THING
TO USE IN THE WORLD...
THAT'S
A GOOD QUESTION.
...AND WHY DID THAT CATCH
THAT SIZE FISH?
GOOD QUESTION.
I'VE BEEN A FISHERMAN
MY WHOLE LIFE.
I STARTED FISHING WHEN
I WAS AGE 2 IN THE SEWER --
AND PROBABLY A GOOD THING
I NEVER CAUGHT ANYTHING THERE.
BUT AT 8, I MADE A FLY
OUT OF MY GRANDMOTHER'S PARROT.
AND I HATED THAT THING.
IT ALWAYS ATTACKED ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND WHEN IT DIED, SHE SAID,
"WOULD YOU BURY IT FOR ME?"
I SAID, "YEAH, YEAH, YEAH."
I TIED 12 FLIES OUT OF IT.
I CAUGHT A TROUT.
IT PUT ME ON THE FRONT PAGE
OF THE TOWN NEWSPAPER.
[ LAUGHS ]
WITH HER DEAD PARROT?
WITH THE FLIES I MADE
FROM HER FEATHERS, YEAH.
I BECAME, LIKE,
A CELEBRITY IN TOWN.
I HAD THIS BIG TROUT.
OH, YOU ARE THE MAN.
SO, WHEN I CAME UP WITH
THIS PRODUCT,
I KNEW THAT THESE FISH
ARE SOUND-DRIVEN.
THEY HUNT THROUGH SOUND
AND VIBRATION FIRST.
THEY'RE ALL NEARSIGHTED.
SO, YOU PULL IT ALONG...
YEP.
...AND IT MAKES
THIS SOUND...
THAT'S RIGHT.
...AS IT'S GOING ALONG
THE BOTTOM?
IT'S TRICKING THE FISH --
ABSOLUTELY, IT'S TRICKING
THE FISH INTO THINKING
THERE'S SOMETHING THERE
THAT IT ISN'T.
WHY DID NOBODY
THINK OF THIS BEFORE?
NOBODY'S AS SMART AS ME.
GREG,
THIS IS JUST...
[ LAUGHS ]
[ LAUGHS ] I LIKE YOU --
HUMBLE, THE HUMBLEBRAG.
Greiner: HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN
SELLING THESE,
AND WHERE
ARE YOU SELLING THESE?
I JUST STARTED SELLING THEM
TWO YEARS AGO.
WHEN I BROKE THE WORLD RECORD,
I MEAN, THAT WAS
MY SECRET WEAPON FOR YEARS.
YOU KNOW, I DID A LOT
OF RESEARCH ON THE SOUND.
I GOT THE DECIBEL LEVELS DOWN.
IT'S PART OF MY PATENT CLAIMS.
YOU HAVE A PATENT
ON THIS?
YEAH.
WELL, HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD?
HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD?
I'VE SOLD 7,000 SO FAR.
THAT'S ALL.
7,000 UNITS?
YES.
HOW MUCH?
Greiner: FOR HOW MUCH?
IT RETAILS AT $6.35.
IT WHOLESALES AT --
SO YOUR SALES ARE AROUND, WHAT,
$40,000 OVER THREE YEARS?
ABOUT $55,000.
SO YOU'RE NOT
THE SMARTEST GUY IN THE WORLD.
NO, I'M NOT A GREAT BUSINESSMAN,
BUT I'M A GOOD FISHERMAN.
THAT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS.
I'M SORRY, $55,000 IN SALES
OVER THREE YEARS?
RIGHT.
John: WHERE HAVE YOU BEEN
SELLING THIS --
ONLINE
OR IN RETAIL STORES?
MOSTLY AT JUST
FISHING TRADE SHOWS.
AND I'D WORKED MY BUTT OFF TO
MAKE THEM MYSELF IN MY BASEMENT.
WAIT, YOU'RE MAKING THESE
YOURSELF, STILL?
YEAH, I MADE --
WELL, NO, NOW I JUST GOT TO THE
POINT WHERE I GOT MY I.P. READY,
I GOT THE TRADEMARK NAME.
IS THAT YOUR RETAIL PACKAGING
RIGHT THERE?
IT'S A WHOLE BUNCH
OF DIFFERENT SIZES?
ACTUALLY, I MADE THAT
AS A DISPLAY.
I MADE THAT AS A DISPLAY.
I MADE IT MYSELF.
WHICH IS
THE RETAIL PACKAGE?
THERE IS NONE.
OH, IT'S THOSE LITTLE
PLASTIC PACKAGES IN FRONT.
Cuban: WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
LET ME UNDERSTAND.
SO, BASICALLY,
YOU'RE NOT AN ENTREPRENEUR YET.
YOU'RE STILL A WANT-TREPRENEUR,
AND YOU'RE STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE IT ALL OUT.
THIS IS THE VERY BEGINNING
STAGES OF THIS COMPANY, YES.
OKAY, SO, IN
THE BAIT-AND-TACKLE BUSINESS...
MM-HMM.
...THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF VERY LARGE PLAYERS
THAT MANUFACTURE AND DISTRIBUTE
TO ALL THE TACKLE SHOPS
ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
RIGHT. RIGHT.
SO, IS IT REALLY
THE VALUE OF WHAT YOU'VE GOT,
THE POTENTIAL PATENT
THAT YOU COULD GO LICENSE
TO A LARGE PLAYER
THAT MAKES THIS STUFF?
'CAUSE YOU HAVE NO DISTRIBUTION,
YOU HAVE NO PACKAGING.
COULD DO THAT.
THIS IS MORE OF
AN INFOMERCIAL PLAY,
BECAUSE YOU WOULD NOT KNOW
WHAT THIS IS.
YEAH, IS THAT PART OF
THE PROBLEM, GREG --
WELL, YOU HAVE TO
HEAR IT.
AND YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S ACOUSTICS.
IT WOULD SIT THERE,
YOU KNOW?
THERE ISN'T A PROBLEM.
I REALLY WASN'T READY
TO MASS-PRODUCE IT YET.
WHAT ARE YOU SELLING, AND FOR --
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU?
THE 5-OUNCE RETAILS
AT $6.45.
AND WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE?
$2.50.
I'M GONNA SIMPLIFY
THIS WHOLE THING, RIGHT?
I INVESTED IN A COMPANY
CALLED SHELL BOBBERS.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU THE EXACT
SAME OFFER I MADE TO THEM --
$80,000 FOR 33%.
OKAY.
THAT'S A GREAT OFFER.
YOU'LL STILL BE
THE FRONT MAN.
YOU'LL STILL DO
ALL THE THINGS THAT YOU DO,
RIGHT, IN DEVELOPING IT
AND PUTTING IT TOGETHER.
SURE.
BUT LET THEM TAKE OVER
THE WHOLE THING.
THE SHELL BOBBER GUYS?
THE SHELL BOBBER GUYS, YEAH,
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN WALMART.
THEY KNOW HOW TO SELL.
YOU GOT TO SAY
YES OR NO.
WHY AREN'T YOU TAKING
THE OFFER?
I LIKE THE OFFER --
BEFORE WE SHAKE ON IT,
COULD I HEAR WHAT
THE OTHER PEOPLE HAVE TO SAY?
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
GREG, I'LL MAKE IT REALLY EASY.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
John: LET ME MAKE IT
EVEN EASIER FOR YOU.
YOU BETTER TAKE
THAT OFFER NOW.
WELL, WAIT -- GREG, LET ME
GIVE YOU AN OFFER HERE.
OH, MY GOD.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
SHELL BOBBER
IS THE BIGGEST PLAYER.
WE ALL KNOW WHAT KEVIN --
AND THE TYPE OF OFFERS HE MAKES,
RIGHT?
MM-HMM.
SO I'M GONNA PUT YOU
ON THE SPOT.
OKAY.
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD MY OFFER. HOW
DO YOU KNOW WHAT YOU WANT TO DO?
COME ON.
IF YOU WANT TO LISTEN TO KEVIN,
THAT'S FINE. I'M OUT.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO LISTEN
TO KEVIN AND TAKE MY OFFER --
'CAUSE YOU KNOW PRETTY MUCH THE
KIND OF OFFER HE'S GONNA MAKE.
THAT'S INTERESTING, 'CAUSE
MY OFFER MAY BE MUCH BETTER.
WHO'S THE NUMBER-ONE
TACKLE MANUFACTURER?
LET SOMEBODY ELSE
DO EVERYTHING ELSE
AND GET A PAYCHECK
EVERY MONTH.
SHELL BOBBER
IS INTERESTING...
YOU GOT TO MAKE UP
YOUR MIND.
...BUT IT'S
A SMALL COMPANY.
MAKE HIM AN OFFER.
IF YOU REALLY BELIEVE IN
YOUR PRODUCT...
THIS IS
THE MR. WONDERFUL TRAP.
I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT THE OFFER IS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT,
OR YOU WANT TO HEAR IT?
YOU GOT TO DECIDE.
YOUR MONEY'S ON THE TABLE.
YOU MAY GO TO SLEEP
AND ALWAYS WONDER.
NO, I'M JUST SAYING.
YOU GOT TO MAKE A DECISION.
YOUR MONEY'S ON THE TABLE, GREG.
GREG, IT'S YOUR MOMENT!
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
'CAUSE THE MINUTE HE SPITS OUT
THAT OFFER, I'M OUT.
YOUR FELLOW FISHERMAN IS TELLING
YOU YOU'D BETTER TAKE THIS.
YOU KNOW, THESE OPPORTUNITIES
ONLY COME AROUND
ONCE IN A LIFETIME.
DUN, DUH, DUN, DUH
MARK,
I'LL TAKE THE DEAL.
YOU GOT IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
John: OH, MY GOD.
THANK YOU, MAN.
YEAH, IT'LL BE GREAT.
ONE WORLD CHAMP
TO ANOTHER, MAN.
ABSOLUTELY, MAN.
WE'LL HAVE FUN WITH IT.
THANK YOU.
YOU WOULD HAVE NEVER HEARD
HOW MUCH YOU WERE GONNA MAKE.
THAT'S RIGHT,
'CAUSE YOU WOULDN'T.
I APPRECIATE IT.
GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU GUYS.
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CONGRATS, CHAMP.
Myerson:
AS A KID, GROWING UP FISHING,
CATCHING A WORLD RECORD, NOW
GETTING A DEAL ON "SHARK TANK."
MAN, WHO'S BETTER THAN ME, HUH?
THIS IS GREAT. I LOVE THIS.
YES!
LORI,
WHEN DID YOU GO FISHING?
I HAVE BEEN FISHING
MANY TIMES -- WITH LEECHES.
WITH LEECHES?
YEAH.
AND DOES KEVIN LIKE FISHING
WHEN YOU TAKE HIM?
[ LAUGHTER ]
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
ARE ACCESSORIES
TO HELP CHANGE UP YOUR LOOK
IN A SNAP.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS KONRAD BILLETZ.
AND I'M KEVIN HABICH.
AND TODAY,
WE'RE SEEKING $150,000
FOR 3.5% STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY, FRAMERI.
WHY IS IT THAT I HAVE A CLOSET
FILLED WITH 20 PAIRS OF SHOES,
10 SUITS, 15 PAIRS OF PANTS,
AND 15 SHIRTS,
BUT I ONLY OWN
ONE PAIR OF GLASSES?
SO THAT'S WHY WE CREATED
FRAMERI.
WITH FRAMERI, NOW YOU CAN
CHANGE YOUR GLASSES
AS EASY AS YOU CHANGE
THE REST OF YOUR OUTFITS.
BUY THE PRESCRIPTION LENSES
THAT YOU NEED
AND SNAP THEM INTO THE FRAMES
THAT YOU WANT.
SO, LET'S SHOW YOU
HOW IT WORKS.
WHILE THESE ALL MIGHT LOOK LIKE
NORMAL PAIRS OF GLASSES,
THEY AREN'T.
WE'VE DESIGNED OUR FRAMES
AND OUR LENSES
SO THAT YOU CAN EASILY
SNAP THE LENSES IN AND OUT.
THIS MAKES IT POSSIBLE
TO USE THE SAME LENS
AND MOVE THAT LENS IN BETWEEN
MULTIPLE QUALITY FRAMES.
AND PUTTING YOU LENSES IN
IS A SNAP.
AND WE ALSO OFFER
SUN LENSES,
SO ALL OF YOUR
AWESOME FRAMERI GLASSES
CAN BECOME SUNGLASSES,
AS WELL.
SO, WHAT DO YOU SAY,
SHARKS?
WHO WANTS TO HELP US
CHANGE HOW PEOPLE SEE?
NOW KEVIN'S GOING TO BE BRINGING
YOU SOME OF OUR PRODUCT.
NOW, THESE ARE OUR PACKAGES
THAT ACTUALLY GET SENT
TO ALL OF OUR CUSTOMERS.
IN EACH OF YOUR BOXES,
YOU'RE GONNA SEE THERE'S THREE
FRAMES AND TWO SETS OF LENSES.
OH, EASY.
IT'LL SNAP RIGHT IN.
VERY GOOD.
VERY EASY.
THIS MEANS THAT YOU HAVE
SIX PAIRS OF GLASSES THERE.
THAT RETAILS FOR $500
ON OUR WEBSITE.
WE DO $100 FRAMES
AND $100 LENSES --
VERY SIMPLE PRICING.
OOH, LOOKING GOOD.
[ LAUGHS ]
I'M LIKING THOSE.
BOLD CHOICE.
LET'S SEE.
THOSE LOOK GOOD.
YEAH?
John:
SO, KONRAD AND KEVIN, UNLESS
MY VISION IS A LITTLE BLURRY,
DID YOU OFFER
3.5% FOR $150,000?
WE DID.
DID YOUR MOTHER DROP YOU
ON YOUR HEAD, AS WELL?
[ CHUCKLES ]
YOU CAN PROVE ME WRONG
BY TELLING ME YOUR SALES
THIS LAST YEAR.
SURE. SO, WE ARE ONLY OPEN
FOR PREORDERS RIGHT NOW.
WE'VE SOLD
$70,000 WORTH.
OVER WHAT PERIOD OF TIME,
KONRAD?
WE OPENED UP PREORDERS
IN OCTOBER.
AND WE ACTUALLY RAN
A CROWDFUNDING CAMPAIGN.
HOW MUCH DID YOU RAISE
ON CROWDFUNDING?
$64,000.
WHAT WAS YOUR GOAL?
$30,000.
YOU DOUBLED YOUR GOAL?
YEAH.
LUXOTTICA DOES 90% OF THE FRAMES
ON EARTH,
WHICH NOBODY KNOWS
THAT BRAND.
IT'S RE-BRANDED
BY EVERYBODY ELSE.
WHY COULDN'T
THEY CRUSH YOU
LIKE THE EYEGLASS COCKROACHES
YOU ARE RIGHT NOW?
SO, WE HAVE SEVERAL
PROVISIONAL PATENTS PENDING.
WE HAVE THE UTILITY PATENT
ON THE LOCK-AND-KEY MECHANISM
OF HOW OUR LENS
SNAPS INTO THE FRAME.
TO ME, I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW YOU COULD GET A PATENT,
'CAUSE I'VE SEEN LENSES
THAT POP IN AND OUT.
SO, WE HAD TO COMPLETELY CHANGE
HOW THE FRAMES ARE MANUFACTURED.
THESE AREN'T INJECTION-MOLDED.
THESE ARE HANDMADE.
SO, WHERE WAS
THE PROPRIETARY PART?
THE PROPRIETARY PART
IS IN
HOW WE ACTUALLY CUT
THE INSIDE SOCKET OF THE FRAME.
THIS RING -- THERE'S
A TON OF TECHNOLOGY TO THIS.
IT TOOK US A YEAR
TO ENGINEER THIS.
SO, CAN I CHOOSE
MY FRAMES?
HOW DO I OPTIMIZE
AND EVEN MAKE MYSELF
EVEN MORE ATTRACTIVE THAN I AM?
FRAMES THAT MAKE YOU INVISIBLE,
MAYBE?
[ LAUGHS ]
I WAS WAITING
FOR YOU.
Billetz: WE ALLOW YOU TO
ACTUALLY CUSTOMIZE YOUR GLASSES
ON THE WEBSITE,
SO YOU CAN SEE
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA LOOK LIKE
BEFORE THEY GET SHIPPED TO YOU.
HERE'S AN EXAMPLE --
CAN YOU SEE THEM
ON YOUR FACE?
Habich: YEAH.
OH, YOU CAN. OKAY.
YEAH, AND WE ACTUALLY HAVE
AN AUGMENTED-REALITY PLUG-IN
THAT WE USE, SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY
TRY THE LENSES ON YOUR FACE.
Herjavec:
OH, THAT'S COOL.
WE ALSO OFFER
FREE SHIPPING AND RETURNS.
SO, THEN, WITH ALL THIS CUSTOM
AND PROPRIETARY MANUFACTURING,
WALK US THROUGH THE COSTS.
WALK US THROUGH
WHAT YOU SELL THEM FOR.
SO, OUR FRAMES COST US
ABOUT $27,
AND OUR LENSES COST US
RIGHT AROUND $10.
John:
I WANT TO GET TO SOMETHING,
'CAUSE I HAVEN'T HEARD
THE ANSWER.
AGAIN, YOU'RE ASKING FOR
A VALUATION OF OVER $4 MILLION.
YOU HAVE ONLY PREORDERED
$70,000 WORTH OF PRODUCT.
WHY ARE YOU VALUING
AT THAT COST?
ARE YOU HERE TO GET EXPOSURE
OR GET EXPOSED?
WHICH ONE?
YOU'RE ASKING FOR
A VALUATION OF OVER $4 MILLION.
WHY ARE YOU VALUING
AT THAT COST?
ARE YOU HERE TO GET EXPOSURE
OR GET EXPOSED?
WHICH ONE?
WE CAME HERE
TO MAKE A DEAL.
YOU CAME HERE TO MAKE A DEAL,
BUT 3.5% --
WE WANT TO MAKE A DEAL.
WELL, LET'S TALK.
I MEAN, WE'RE VERY, VERY HAPPY
TO TALK. WE CAME HERE --
LET ME TRY TO --
WAIT, BUT WHAT
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
'CAUSE YOU GOT TO UNDERSTAND
ONE THING.
AND MAYBE THE OTHER GUYS FEEL
A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
THAT FLOOR RIGHT THERE IS FOR
PEOPLE THAT DESPERATELY NEED
A SHOT AND ACCESS
TO CAPITAL.
THEY'RE NOT SOMEBODY
THAT RAISED A MILLION DOLLARS,
DIDN'T EVEN
LAUNCH SOMETHING.
LET ME ASK
SOME QUESTIONS NOW.
I WANT TO HEAR THIS!
LET THEM ANSWER IT.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO GET
THE WRONG IMPRESSION.
I'M FROM
A SMALL TOWN IN IDAHO.
I'VE TRIED TO LAUNCH
OTHER COMPANIES
AND LIVED IN MY CAR.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
I'VE BEEN THERE.
WHAT DOES THAT
HAVE TO DO WITH
YOU VALUING THE COMPANY
OVER $4 MILLION?
LET ME ASK
SOME QUESTIONS.
WELL, MARK,
I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT YOU,
BUT IT BOTHERS ME, TOO.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND --
YOU HAVEN'T REALLY SOLD
OR HAD EXPERIENCE
WITH THIS PRODUCT WHATSOEVER.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOUR RETURN RATE'S GONNA BE.
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW WELL
THE QUALITY IS GONNA HOLD UP.
YOU DON'T KNOW
A LOT OF THINGS.
AND YOU DO COME IN HERE
VALUING IT
AT A RIDICULOUS AMOUNT,
FOR HAVING NO EXPERIENCE.
I HATE WHEN I HEAR THIS
FROM THE OTHER SHARKS.
I JUST HATE IT,
HATE IT, HATE IT.
THIS IS NOT ONLY
FOR THE DESPERATE.
IF SOMEONE HAS A GOOD IDEA AND
COME IN HERE AND SELL US ON IT
THEY CAN GET
AN INVESTOR...
NO, BUT, MARK, WE DON'T
HAVE TO AGREE WITH YOU.
...JUST LIKE THEY WENT
TO OTHER INVESTORS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M SAYING, AND
I DON'T HAVE TO AGREE WITH YOU.
I DON'T AGREE
WITH YOU.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW YOU COME IN ASKING FOR THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE
JUST NO EXPERIENCE WITH IT YET.
WE DON'T HAVE
SOMEBODY ON OUR TEAM
AS AN INVESTOR
THAT CAN BUILD A BRAND.
THAT'S TRUE.
WE NEED TO BECOME A BRAND.
WE WANT TO GO INTERNATIONAL.
I DON'T SEE
PROOF OF CONCEPT.
WHAT IS YOUR
CUSTOMER-ACQUISITION COST
GOING TO BE,
DO YOU ANTICIPATE?
IN THE STARTUP STAGE FOR TYPICAL
E-COMMERCE GLASSES COMPANIES,
IT'S $5 TO $15.
WHEN THEY MOVE INTO
THE GROWTH STAGE,
IT'S CLOSER
TO $20 TO $30.
OKAY, SO, LET'S TAKE
THE WORST-CASE SCENARIO.
DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH RUNWAY CASH
TO STAY ALIVE FOR 24 MONTHS,
IF IT'S A $25
CUSTOMER-ACQUISITION COST?
YEAH, WHAT'S YOUR CASH-TO-DEBT
RIGHT NOW?
SO, OUR BURN RATE'S
ROUGHLY $38,000 A MONTH.
MOST OF IT GOES TO SALARY.
THAT'S PRETTY LEAN.
MY CHALLENGE IS, WE ALL UP HERE
HAVE DIFFERENT FUNDAMENTALS
IN WHAT WE BELIEVE
IN BUSINESS.
I'M A GUY WHO BELIEVES
THAT YOU SHOULD SHOW
THAT YOU HAVE PROOF OF CONCEPT,
THEN YOU BUILD A BUSINESS,
AND YOU BRING IN INVESTORS ONCE
YOU PROVE THAT THE MODEL WORKS
AND YOU CAN RETURN MONEY.
I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE FULL OF B.S. OR NOT,
SO I DON'T WANT
TO CHOP YOU DOWN.
I JUST HAVE
A VERY FUNNY FEELING
THAT YOU'RE NOT THE RIGHT PERSON
FOR ME.
AND TO SUM IT ALL UP,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
WELL, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I REALLY APOLOGIZE
THAT YOU FEEL THAT WAY.
KEVIN -- KEVIN, IS IT TRUE
THAT YOU'RE A SILENT PARTNER?
YOU HAVEN'T SAID ANYTHING.
Habich: NO.
[ LAUGHS ]
I'M JUST NOT
THE FINANCIAL GUY.
OKAY.
AND IT'S ALL
VALUATION QUESTIONS.
I GET IT.
LET ME JUST JUMP IN
FOR A MINUTE.
I THINK THE GLASSES LOOK GREAT
AND THE QUALITY'S NICE.
THE PROBLEM, FOR ME, IS
WHEN YOU HAVE A PRODUCT,
TRY IT, TEST IT, SEE,
BEFORE YOU START RAISING
ALL SORTS OF MONEY.
SO FOR ME, I DON'T THINK I HAVE
THE SAME PHILOSOPHY AS YOU,
AND FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
WELL, THANK YOU.
KONRAD, I DON'T HAVE
A PROBLEM WITH BIG BETS.
I MEAN,
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL DESIGN.
IT LOOKS GREAT.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I MEAN, IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S WORTH
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
YOU'RE SELLING IT FOR.
MY ONLY ISSUE IS I WISH YOU HAD
A LITTLE MORE EXPERIENCE.
I'M NOT FAULTING YOU
FOR IT,
'CAUSE YOU GOT TO START
SOMEWHERE, RIGHT?
YOU'RE ONLY
A FIRST-TIME C.E.O. ONCE.
RIGHT.
AND IT'S JUST
THAT LEVEL OF UNCERTAINTY --
NOT A NEGATIVE,
JUST THAT'S HOW I FEEL.
SO...
I'M GONNA BE OUT.
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND.
FIRST OF ALL,
I DON'T CARE WHERE VALUATION IS.
I CARE ABOUT
WHERE VALUATION CAN GO.
MM-HMM.
AND YOU MENTIONED TO KEVIN
THAT THERE WAS
A $25 CUSTOMER-ACQUISITION COST
THAT YOU ESTIMATE.
SO, HOW ARE YOU SPENDING
THAT $25?
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE NOT.
OUR GO-TO-MARKET STRATEGY'S
REALLY BASED AROUND THREE AREAS.
IT'S AROUND, YOU KNOW,
BUILDING AWARENESS --
HOW ARE YOU GONNA
BUILD AWARENESS?
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
AN AWESOME FASHION P.R. AGENCY,
AN E-COMMERCE P.R. AGENCY, IN
NEW YORK, TO PREPARE FOR LAUNCH.
SO, BUT -- OKAY, SO, YOU'RE
GONNA GET YOUR BLAST OF P.R.
YEP.
THEN WHAT?
OUR PRODUCT --
'CAUSE IT'S NOT
AN INHERENTLY VIRAL PRODUCT.
IT'S DESIGNED TO SHARE,
RIGHT?
IF YOU AND YOUR FRIEND
BOTH HAVE TITLE FRAMES,
YOU CAN ACTUALLY
SWAP YOUR FRAMES.
IN ADDITION,
THERE'S THIS --
THAT'S A STRETCH.
[ LAUGHS ]
IT'S A NICE TRY,
BUT IT'S A STRETCH.
AND I THINK -- I THINK --
I THINK THE REAL KEY
IS THAT THERE'S --
LOOK IN THE MARKET,
ALL RIGHT?
YOU SEE EVERYBODY SELLING
THE EXACT SAME PRODUCT.
BUT YOU HAVEN'T
EXPLAINED TO ME
HOW YOU'RE GONNA CONVEY THAT
TO A POTENTIAL BUYER,
OTHER THAN SWAPPING LENSES,
IF SOMEONE ALREADY HAS IT.
SO PRODUCT, GREAT.
MM-HMM.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF BEAUTIFUL
PRODUCTS THAT HAVE DIED.
THE FACT THAT
I DON'T SEE YOU AS HAVING
A VERY SPECIFIC GO-TO-MARKET
STRATEGY BEYOND P.R.,
THAT REALLY CONCERNS ME.
IT LEADS ME TO BELIEVE THAT
YOU'RE AMAZING PRODUCT GUYS
BUT DON'T HAVE
THAT OTHER PART FIGURED OUT.
FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
SURE.
AND THEN THERE WAS ONE.
I'M VERY VALUABLE TO YOU
FOR TWO REASONS.
ONE,
I'M THE ONLY SHARK LEFT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
OKAY?
THAT'S USUALLY
THE ONLY REASON.
AND, TWO,
YOU'RE THE ONLY SHARK LEFT.
O'Leary: SECONDLY, MY COMPANIES
GET A LOT OF MEDIA,
BECAUSE I'M A MEDIA WHORE.
IT'S WHAT I DO.
I'M VERY GOOD AT IT.
AND WHAT I THINK I CAN DO,
OR HELP YOU WITH,
IS REDUCE YOUR
CUSTOMER-ACQUISITION COSTS.
IF I CAN MAKE THEM ZERO,
YOU LAST A LOT LONGER.
YEAH, WE WOULD LAST
A VERY LONG TIME.
SO HERE'S THE DEAL
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU $150,000
AS A LOAN.
HERE'S HOW
YOU'RE GONNA PAY ME BACK.
EVERY TIME YOU SELL
ONE OF THESE BOX SETS,
YOU'RE GONNA GIVE ME $25
UNTIL I'VE RECOUPED $450,000.
THEN THE LOAN GOES AWAY.
BUT THERE'S ONE OTHER THING.
YOU'RE GIVING ME
THAT 3.5% EQUITY,
JUST BECAUSE
I'M MR. WONDERFUL.
I THINK YOU'VE DONE A HECK
OF A GOOD JOB GETTING HERE.
I LIKE THE PRODUCT.
BUT YOU ARE IN
A BRUTALLY COMPETITIVE SPACE.
THAT'S MY OFFER.
IT'S THE ONLY ONE.
NO, I DON'T WANT
A COUNTER.
THAT'S FINE.
RIGHT NOW,
I'M JUST IN THE START-UP STAGE.
ANY ROYALTIES
IS VERY, VERY DIFFICULT.
YOU'RE NOT IN
THE START-UP STAGE.
YOU'RE ON THE TRACK.
SURE. UM...
YOU KNOW, UNFORTUNATELY,
I DON'T THINK IT'S AN OFFER
THAT WE CAN TAKE AT THIS TIME.
YOU'RE DEAD TO ME.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU GUYS.
Cuban: GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Billetz:
THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT.
Greiner: BYE.
THANK YOU GUYS.
HAVE A GREAT DAY.
IT'S DISAPPOINTING,
I THINK, FOR BOTH OF US,
TO NOT HAVE A DEAL, BUT WE'RE
GONNA KEEP PUSHING FORWARD,
AND WE'RE GONNA TAKE OUR DREAM
AND MAKE IT A REALITY.
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST "NO"
WE'VE HEARD.
NO, IT'S NOT THE FIR--
WON'T BE THE LAST.